let me go next to jade from
london is this london england london
ontario
london connecticut uh london
england london england all right jade
welcome
hi i didn't actually think this would
happen this is my first discord
ever wow well i'm glad it's with me
yeah me too um so i i'm a bit fascinated
at the moment with america i've never
been
um hold on let me know let me clarify
jade you've never been to america or
you've never
before been fascinated with it uh
probably
both both okay all right good very good
um
but um so the election it essentially
turned me nocturnal because i was hooked
um and that's actually how i found your
channel um
and so i i've got a theory to run past
you and i think you may be the only one
to kind of answer this question
please um just because it might may come
off as a bit of a conspiracy theory
perfect um we know that trump is in
hundreds of millions of dollars in debt
right um
we also now there's reports coming out
he's selling loads of arms
to dangerous people all over the job all
over the shop yes
um is it
my my theory is that he
is selling all of these things making
backdoor deals and all of these kind of
things and i think he was banking
on the fact that he still had four more
years as president as president
because he may have some sort of payment
plan or something like this to pay back
all of
his debts um and where he doesn't have
that anymore
a lot of these things are falling
through and i think that's probably why
he's panicking and doing what he's doing
and
dragging out the inevitable well that's
kind of my theory it's
it's not it's not a crazy theory in this
sense
jade which is i do think that
trump believes that the 400
or so million that will in debt that
will come due over the next four years
he would be in a stronger position to
either renegotiate or somehow get parts
of it written off or something
if he were the sitting president rather
than a former president i think that's
undeniably true
now the specifics about whether the arms
deals are related to it or these
i don't know about that that's
definitely more speculative but i think
you're absolutely correct that
trump would rather have 400 million in
debt come due
while being president then than not
that's a it's a position of power
there's no doubt about that
mm-hmm yeah no because people are
talking to me like
i say these things might this theory
also like slightly stems from the fact
that the simpsons have predicted
everything and trump dying
so i genuinely think that all of this
may push him
to the edge that's more something will
happen
to you but listen aside from the
simpsons
trump is an overweight mid-seventies guy
who hasn't exercised ever um
so i mean it's not crazy to think that
donald trump's
health may be in question i i mean i
don't not to get morbid but it's not a
crazy thing to be thinking about
yeah yeah or maybe that's maybe that's a
little bit wishful thinking concerning
that we both have our
own mini trump over here yeah now of
course i would never win
i don't know about you jade i would
never wish death or illness upon anybody
i just want them to go away politically
you might wish death on some okay fair
enough i see you hesitating there
okay jade our connection has just gotten
very poor so i really appreciate the
call hope to hear from you again there
is
uh there's jade from london whose call i
very much appreciate
uh that is going to do it for calls
today i'm sorry i was not able to get to
more but we will take calls again
we're going to take a quick break on the
podcast tv show and radio show
and be back with much more right after
this
if you love feeding your intellectual
curiosity but you're always
struggling to find the time check out
one of my all-time
favorite apps called blinkist blinkist
lets you consume an entire book
on your way home from work they take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
condense each one into text or audio
that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important
core ideas and information from that
book it's perfect
if you don't have enough time to do all
the reading you want to do
or if you just want to sample a book
before you buy the entire thing
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great stephen hawking
this is a book that i have been aware of
for so long and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic to check it out on blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about
eight bucks a month and you get the
entire library
but you can try it totally free and get
25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
pacman i've put the link right
underneath this video